you had brought up about how you think
that boys and girls can't be friends and
um i had my mind changed on that because
i was on the other side where i had
mostly guy friends and then steve
brought up a lot of great points and it
made me change my mind how did you come
to that because i know that's what a lot
of people wanted to hear about
[Music]
hello everybody welcome back to big mood
we got a very special guest in the house
the one and only stacy diaz yeah
she is joining us for quite a few
episodes today so i'm very excited for
you to see all of those if you haven't
watched the ones she's been in already
we love her she's been part of the fan
for a long time basically since
inception like one of our original
guests
inception
uh who else we got uh yeah gina here hi
yeah and tiff and we got nikki uh jess
is missing today we kicked her out
because there can only be one dog lady
at a time there's a huge sale there's a
huge sale on mason jars and you know
there's a huge sale on live laugh love
jess is like raging on the camera right
now she's changed texas and
[Laughter]
while she's putting up a [ __ ] um
she's all in the wood place
we love you jess she actually picked out
this topic today that we're talking
about and i think stacy's the perfect
guest for this because um you are
empower women and
you said you grew up around a lot of
women right i did yeah
so do you want to tell me yeah so we're
talking about
are you trying to just go
do your job
do you want your job
right go ahead talk about
about toxic femininity today which is a
term i guess coined because um toxic
masculinity has been around for a while
as a talking point for a lot of
feminists and so uh recently women are
also like wait hey there's a lot of
toxic femininity too where like girls
think you can only girl one way and they
really harshly judge other women um if
you're not doing it correct the correct
way that all women should be doing it
which is super toxic um is this the same
thing as like pikmi's
i know this is like the opposite of
pikmi pygmies are like i'm different
because i'm not like them these are the
themes that are like you're not one of
us
yeah and i have so many terms yeah i
know there's a lot of terms i didn't
grow up with a lot of women so that's
why i'm very curious on your experiences
and i have a little listicle that we're
gonna touch on that just sent over and
maybe you can say like i mean everybody
but like i'm more specifically curious
just yeah as someone that's grown up
around the world let's see what you've
experienced any of these things okay so
um the first one is uh bagging on other
women for women differently than they do
some women will feel nothing about
letting you know how you are parenting
wrong by using x product or letting your
child do why a particular thing it
becomes really toxic especially after
someone gives birth dude wait can we
touch it point by point yeah because you
know what i was gonna say about this i
haven't experienced it myself
but
i think mothers get that a lot yeah or
pregnant people because i feel like i
you obviously we all follow influencers
who we love and we watch for a long time
and all of a sudden they'll become
pregnant and then they'll be crying on
their story because they're like you
guys are literally attacking me for
eating like sushi yeah and my doctor
said it was okay you know so yeah that
sounds horrible and scary you know yeah
but it's not even that's not exclusively
reserved for just influencers because
literally anyone like just in society
especially like for me personally i had
the
i had to face the criticisms of oh
you're just a little girl you're a
teenager
i was 18 when isaac was born but i was
17 throughout my pregnancy
and so they're just like oh you don't
know what you're talking about or like i
had no
like i had no say over my own pregnancy
or like how i wanted to raise my son or
nothing because it's like oh you're just
a little girl like you don't know
anything
so other women would treat you like that
yeah women would treat me like that and
even like my own doctors like yeah i was
so i had to go through the teen mom [ __ ]
and the typical like woman crap where
it's like oh this is how i did it this
is how you should do it see this is what
um confuses me because i feel like women
are all about body autonomy and like
freeing yourself so that you are free to
do what you want with your body but then
they police other women's bodies and
that's that's really weird you know what
i think it is i i mean obviously
we have the unique experience of having
a bunch of people watching us when we're
going through these things but i think
it's a fact that
women don't really ever get to tell you
like let's say you would dye your hair
red i've never i've never done my hair
red so i can't tell you how to do it
right but because so many women have
been pregnant and different things work
for them they feel like because it's
your first time doing it they have a
right to tell you yeah what to do or how
to do it or what you're doing wrong and
i've watched like i have some friends
um who one just gave birth and one's
currently pregnant right now one's 21
the other one's 23. their names are
blank and shout out to them if you guys
are here because you watch them but
they are influencers and they're really
young and some of the messages that they
post that people will tell them like
oh that's why you shouldn't be having
babies you're too young this is a full
grown woman like she's 21 and 23. like
you don't ever get to say who gets to
have a kid or not yeah i don't like the
the judgment that like extremist
judgment of just like this it's black
and white and it's like and i think it's
the fact that maybe some of these toxic
women have had one child or several
children so they think that they're
experts
everyone online is an expert that's what
i've noticed about every single subject
you ever bring up is that everyone in
the comment section is an experiment i
think especially on pregnancy because i
don't ever really get it on anything
else you know like obviously i work out
right and there's been times where
people tell me you're doing that wrong
and i'm like girl i'm not but you do
what you want to do oh yeah working out
what your diet is yeah but see like
those things i guess i don't really get
do you guys get them for other things
um
uh for my language yeah they're like you
know real men or women should not cuss
like that because oh yeah i don't like
it but i feel like i got that from guys
too so i grew up in um you know catholic
like filipino
house and so like i naturally say i'm
pigeon toad i don't know if it has
anything to do with this but i just
naturally sit with my legs open like i
just like it's the most comfortable
position for me and my
elders would always scold me for like
sitting with my legs open but the guys
could sit with their legs open and i
just didn't think that was fair it's not
like i'm wearing a skirt i'm wearing
jeans like i just didn't make sense to
me is toxic feminine femininity like um
like you shouldn't dress like that
because it's not ladylike yeah
i see so it's very old-school thinking
yeah like thinking that you should women
one particular way um i wonder if you're
going to get this though because this
kind of happened while i was planning a
wedding because i didn't know what i was
doing at all like i said um and i was
very vocal about how one i didn't know
what i was doing and two i didn't really
care that much about like
doing it the right way i just wanted to
have fun and like make the day like
special with whoever was there and um
but i've seen a lot of women uh
talk about other women planning their
weddings wrong or even in their own
family like the mom will
say that they should do
do it a certain way and the bride
doesn't even want to do it that way but
the mom or the other older females in
the family
will try to control the wedding i had a
girlfriend who just got married and she
said that she had to deal with a lot of
her family members especially like the
women in the family they were upset that
my friend
wanted a no children wedding
and and then i go to her wedding and
there's a [ __ ] ton of kids
even though she was just like no kids
like they still were like [ __ ] i'm
bringing my kids yeah i said no kids and
people didn't listen yeah it's like it
was fine but i'm just like sure
but it's your day you're the one paying
for it like come on sure but yeah sorry
you were gonna say something um no i
mean i haven't got it i've got my mom
who's like why are you gonna get that or
this or that but i don't think i think
for this specific topic it's more like
you know when you go to the gym and then
there's women that are like why is she
wearing all that makeup she's at the gym
and it's like [ __ ] it's her life let
her live she might have just gotten off
work yeah like or or maybe she got ready
to go to the gym like what is it
probably toxic femininity right because
then like going back to the whole like
pregnancy stuff and the parenting stuff
like
there is i feel like because i already
have a kid right like i know i've been
through this
i have friends that will get pregnant
i'm so excited for them yeah i
don't like i guess i can see how these
women can get into the mentality of like
i'm so excited for you i want you to
learn from my mistakes like this is what
i did um and you know like this is your
first time like go ahead and learn from
me like yeah
that's probably the intention behind it
but the execution comes off really
condescending and patronizing and really
like toxic so there's a way to say it
and go about it and also respect the
autonomy of that person like
exactly what they would want to do for
themselves is just like oh here's a
suggestion if you want it or don't even
[ __ ] say anything and if you're like
i don't know if this helps you but this
helped me and then say like what
personally helped you yeah and then when
it gets really really toxic is yeah it's
the judgment of like oh you're doing
that no wonder your kid is going through
this or whatever it is it's like
[ __ ] off like yeah dude not your
business at all that's scary yeah yeah i
don't yeah it's weird though because i'm
i'm trying to think of
if it's just a female thing or not
because i feel like a lot of
comments in my comment section that are
negative like that
they're from guys and girls i was gonna
say that too yeah it actually comes a
lot from guys what do you think about
the pregnancy yes like pregnancy and
childhood and about like just like oh no
wonder blah blah blah or like even like
the single girls on the show on our
comments sometimes they'll be like oh no
wonder they're single because they have
too high standards or like whatever
um so yeah it's interesting that's weird
i'm sorry you're settling yeah
or you want other girls to settle for
you yeah yeah exactly oh that just shows
exactly where they see themselves that's
what i think it is i think it's an
insecurity of what
the boy or girl is thinking about
themselves is projected onto someone
else because when you're talking about
oh why is she wearing so much makeup at
the gym i remember my mom commenting
about that before like oh i just can't
handle how some girls have to get
dressed up for the gym but she heard it
from her mom and i think it was
something that she was always conscious
of and then i think a lot of these
things just get
passed down and people don't question
where their judgments are coming from or
some women genuinely like to get ready
and go to the gym and do what they're
gonna do and some women don't but yeah i
wish that none of them did so they
didn't have to step up to that standard
right like i don't wear makeup to gym
anymore i used to but
there's
i don't care what anybody else is doing
yeah literally you know and i think that
maybe sometimes people feel like
oh [ __ ] she looks better so maybe if i
would put makeup on like i'm gonna look
better too
you know but because i don't want to do
the effort i'm just gonna
talk bad about her yeah there was a
saying that i saw online uh it said uh
yeah it's all about women empowerment so
you think she looks better than you and
then that's when girls get mean you know
because like someone else they're like
oh yes queen you look so great
like traditionally um
whatever they're like oh yes yes yes
you're so confident but then if it's
someone that's hot that has like you
know looks great doing whatever they're
like oh she's wearing too much makeup
she's doing that or she's superficial
yeah she's so obsessed with herself or
something like that yeah i've seen a lot
of that that is so true yeah because
even like not even just online like
there's literally people that will envy
other people because they don't see
themselves
like they're not comfortable within
themselves so then they end up like
lashing out with
like
subtle petty like passive-aggressive
comments or looks it's just like i got a
comment saying um
you're just mad because i have a wedding
ring and you don't it was like
yikes
your identity is having a ring on your
finger from some dude you know like
that's wow it doesn't affect yeah people
i think project their own goals or level
like metrics of success on other people
oh you don't have a wedding ring yet
like you haven't made it as a woman like
or no kids you didn't have that you're
not fulfilling your duty as a woman
yeah interesting going back to what you
said though like how it's it's actually
like a lot of the times i feel like
that's true where a lot of this toxic
mentality does get passed on from our
parents that we don't even you don't
think about it yeah you don't question
it you're just like oh that's what they
think okay i guess that's what i'm
thinking too like you don't even really
take the time to analyze like wait why
do i have this judgment or like this
this prejudice against other people for
this one particular thing and then not
until you actually take a second you're
like wait
where is this coming from like oh yeah
like i heard my aunt or my grandma or
whatever like
say this one particular thing and then i
adopted that as my own thought and you
have to question that [ __ ] like wait
that makes no sense
yeah
i i did notice i guess um
because i'm trying to think of examples
where like i've seen when you were
talking about the oh if you think she's
more attractive than you you get mad or
whatever um i i did notice when i was
younger in my 20s i had a boyfriend i've
always been like monogamous like very
like serious relationships back to back
and so i've always been in a
relationship but when i would go by
myself to events and there would be like
couples girls would get like really
guarded with their man and i'm like i'm
not trying to take a man girl like i
don't need your but i like to talk to
everybody like i talk to
guys girls i talk to everyone the same
but they see it as like you're flirting
and they get like i wouldn't get invited
to certain things so it was weird to me
to be taken that way when i felt like i
was treating everyone equally yeah
because at that point you don't realize
that this is their own insecurity yeah
projecting on to you and i also don't
think of myself that way like i don't
think of myself as attractive so like
when
i found out like oh my girlfriend
doesn't like me or doesn't like you
hanging around us or whatever i'm like
wait why i was really hurt by it but
yeah that happened um yeah what's the
second point okay so going down the list
i know i want to read them off yeah
right there's quite a few on here
there's um there's a ton of shaming
everywhere especially online like you're
you're not you're planning on not
medicating god you're not getting a
medal you're
uh you're medicating wow you're so weak
like giving birth yeah i guess so yeah
you're not breastfeeding what are you
abusing your child you're breastfeeding
do you spit on moms who can't jeez
you're going back to work what's wrong
with you don't you love your child oh my
gosh
i saw this thing that a woman said
if you had a c-section you're not a real
man oh that's the next one oh yeah oh
yeah yeah
so they say if you had a c-section
you're not a real mom because secondly
you didn't give birth you just got the
baby removed from you
like how little what like how little do
you have your life so you have to
have to given the birth yeah be a mom
yeah what about adopting moms right like
i just are they not real moms either
like you're not a real mom like it's
it's ridiculous it's like how little do
you have to pride in your life that you
have to latch onto something so crappy
and shitty yeah you have to shame other
people for it yeah i've actually so i i
have thoughts on that because i had
isaac through c-section and my own
personal goal like i'm not judging other
people for having a c-section like
that's it's [ __ ] hard you're still
all that right okay i'm not gonna get
into that for me for myself
i felt really sad and and really like i
felt like a disappointment i felt like i
didn't fully really
i and these were like my own
feelings about myself and my own
experience like i was i had to have a
c-section because isaac was like upside
down like like the wrong position so his
head was up and it's supposed to be down
to give birth naturally so it's called
breach so he was breached
and i found out two days before he was
born that he was breech
and i would the day that he was born i
went in to have a trans version i think
that's what they call it but it's where
they flip them around like from the
outside of the belly oh what does that
feel like well that's the thing when i
went in i was already in labor and
they're supposed to give you a
medication to loosen the uterus and then
you'll do it whatever the point is i was
i i i went to go get that procedure done
because i really wanted to have a
natural birth and i was
so disappointed that i couldn't have
that and i had to have a c-section so
for me and myself i gave myself that
judgment of i didn't work for isaac i
don't i didn't earn him like i didn't
feel like i was
fully a mother but why
i exactly like i don't know
i don't know like i really don't know
why mom tell you that at some point i
don't think i've ever heard this from
anyone does she give natural birth to
all of you yes she did was she pride
herself in that um i don't i don't think
so like i don't really know like where
how i even got this judgment on myself i
think it was just that's why i'm like
emphasizing so much like this was my
experience and this is how i felt
afterwards i felt like i just didn't
earn him
and
i would never put that judgment on other
women like mom [ __ ] no especially after
going through it myself like [ __ ] yeah i
earned him like that's surgery my entire
[ __ ] organs were out like yeah no
that was that was
that was a whole nother thing i had to
stay in the hospital for five days and
yeah you had surgery yeah and then like
with vaginal birth you stay like max too
maybe like maybe three but
yeah like you can leave right away
you're fine you can't even like sit up
because you're cutting into your abs
yeah i couldn't sit up i couldn't even
carry him very well like and then also
like my milk came in so my breasts were
like so like rock hard and like i was in
so much pain and like i [ __ ] earned
him but now i see that but back then
especially with all the criticisms and
all the the judgment of being a team mom
it's like oh [ __ ] like it's another teen
mom exactly it's just like here's
another reason why i'm i'm already
starting off to be a such a horrible
mother because i'm already [ __ ] young
and i didn't earn him with vaginal
delivery like
it's just it's crazy how
how like i i can't even tell you where
that came from for myself yeah but now
looking back i know i was wrong and did
anyone ever tell you that you took the
easy way out that i would i told myself
that oh [ __ ] i literally would tell
myself that and
like i feel bad for being so cruel
yeah
she [ __ ] went through so much plus
you could have died if you try to do it
the natural way there's a reason why
they or the baby
his cord was actually around his neck
yeah they took him out yeah and i mean i
think at the end of the day because all
this judgment that women get from other
women
um i think this is giving birth
naturally is painful and
the more pain you have the more pride
you have after you accomplish something
right
and
for years and years and years has been
done a certain way
but medicine is there to literally make
make our lives easier yeah you know it's
the same baby it's not like you know you
traded it for another one
a better model or a worse model it's the
same kid and
as it is hormone like your hormones
already all over the place and so then
to put this kind of pressure on women
you know like with the whole
breastfeeding thing like you
have you guys heard about like moms who
say like fed is best
do you guys know what that means yeah
that means like even formula formulators
mama you're feeding your baby as long as
you're feeding your baby that's the best
thing you can do right and at the end of
the day like that's
all we can do like our lives are
different
and those women that take so much pride
kind of like the ring girl like oh you
don't have a ring yeah [ __ ] i don't
what's your problem yeah
that doesn't make you a better or worse
woman than i than me right yeah see
that's the part where it doesn't click
for me where i have those judgments and
those
goals for myself i breastfed isaac for
an entire year because i'm like that's
my goal i would love to do that for my
baby like i get to actually
experience that bonding with him and
then try to give him as much nutrition
as i could so it was my it was a goal of
mine but i'm not going to place that
judgment on other women when they can't
there's so many complications a lot of
women can't even get to breastfeed or
even even create that much breast milk
like they don't they can't even like
fully feed their babies sometimes like
there's so many factors in it or the
women are just like oh that's just not
for me i don't want to do that and
that's [ __ ] fine yeah for me for
myself i was like this is my goal i
really want to accomplish this and if i
wasn't able to breastfeed just like how
i was i felt so
down on myself for not giving birth
naturally i know i would have been
really hard on myself if i couldn't
breastfeed either and there's women who
like literally schedule their c-sections
mm-hmm like they're like i'm busy next
week so let's have them this week oh my
gosh
yeah and that's fine they're moms yeah
and they're practical moms i mean we're
in the modern world literally yeah and
um
before we jump more into that we are
going to hear a word from our sponsors
which was recorded by us a long time ago
canada are clear aligners thousands of
people have used candid the clear
comfortable removable and practically
invisible liners to help straighten
their teeth and now they love their
smile your treatment is prescribed and
closely monitored remotely by the same
lysist orthodontist from start to finish
other companies use general dentists but
candid works with actual orthodontists
who are experts in tooth movement you
can book an appointment at a candid
studio near you or do everything from
the comfort and convenience of your own
home the average candid treatment is
just six months and you see results way
before then and it also costs thousands
less than traditional braces also if you
get the aligners you get whitening for
free where else can you get something as
expensive as teeth whitening for free
fresh you get it with candid candid help
you can get straighter brighter smile
you've always wanted and probably need
if you're dating
right now you can save 75 on candid
starter kit go to candidco.com
mood and use code mood
that's candidco.com mood with the code
mood take advantage of this limited time
offer to save 75 on your starter kit
candidco.com mood and use our code mood
and after you finish straightening and
whitening your teeth you're going to
want to take care of those teeth so grab
yourself an electric toothbrush like
bruce
going to the dentist can be a little bit
scary especially if you are anticipating
some surprises oh i didn't floss i
wasn't flossing you need to floss and
you needed to brush oh no i wasn't
brushing my teeth and an electric
toothbrush like bruce can help you have
no surprises because they have so many
different modes that take care of so
many different parts of your mouth you
could you know you got different parts
of your mouth too right like you've got
gums oh you got your your your tongue oh
your teeth oh
all your tooths whatever your teeth
oh you should probably brush that too
okay you're disgusting
your tonsils
down your throat
my favorite feature of this is the
tongue mode actually because it you turn
it over at the end of your tooth
brushing cycle and you put it on tongue
mode and it just like it has this like
bristly thing on the bridge that like
really scrubs out all that bacteria out
of your tongue which is kind of i don't
know if or where i read this but it's
like it's what creates bad breath
in your tongue all the time
your tongue should not be white no clue
you should be hydrating and brushing
that tongue uh there's six unique modes
to customize your brushing experience
it's ha it has a four week battery life
with magnetic charging stand and a
compact travel case which is awesome
because when you travel it's like you
don't want that to get filled with
bacteria so the travel case is perfect
so it's got a really sleek design it's
like matte black i love it it makes your
counter look great and you can get 15
off your bruce toothbrush kit and refill
plan when you use promo code mood at
bruce.com that's 15 off using promo code
mood at b r u u
s sh.com
once again go to bruce.com and use code
mood for 15 off your bruce toothbrush
kit and refill plan okay i hope you
bought whatever we told you to buy but
and we are jumping back into some toxic
femininity here wait before you keep
going yeah i did want to talk about the
the medicated stuff for for birth yes so
right now i'm pregnant and
my goal is to eventually
for this delivery to have
a vaginal birth just like how i wanted
to have with isaac
and
i don't know if that's going to happen
for me
and but this time i know to be kinder to
myself like if i can't like that's just
not in the cards for me but that's my
goal it's also a goal of mine to try to
go
unmedicated too but that's only because
i know my body and i know myself and i
know my mental strength and i
i haven't been through birth like that
i'm i'm not talking
i'm not like trying to say i know
everything right but what i'm saying is
i know
my body can handle a certain amount of
pain and so i it's a personal goal of
mine to try to get there but i am not
completely ruling out getting medicated
if i need to like if i'm just like holy
[ __ ] this is a lot more than i expected
which i probably will i'm it's not out
of the question for me yeah and it's
also not something that i'm gonna hold
against any woman or like make me like
the whole thing about like oh you got a
medal like you're gonna get a medal
because you got you were unmedicated
like
[ __ ] you dude like that's that's their
goal that's their accomplishment if they
see it as an accomplishment whatever it
is it's like everyone gets delivered i
mean there's also like there's a lot of
risks involved with getting the the shot
it's a big shot and they have to get it
very specifically yeah they go into your
ex and so my sister-in-law worked at a
hospital and she said she had seen two
people get paralyzed from it and so she
wasn't when she was giving birth she
wasn't gonna do the medicine because she
was like no [ __ ] that i don't want to
risk that but then she said it was so
painful she gave in and took the
medicine and she called me up like in
her drunken stupor and she was like
nikki when you have a kid just take the
drugs just take the drugs
even my doctor too she was like
i'm not going to say anything like she
even she even made it clear like i'm not
going to judge you if you want the
medication yeah
i'm not even pregnant like the minute i
walk into the hospital sedate me
for any reason
you sedate me
it's just because she was so like
no like absolutely not we are not
medicaid not judging anyone for doing it
but just like her own fear of like i
don't want any of those complications to
happen yeah oh and then she was she
called me and she was like take the
drugs
my aunt had to give birth to triplets
and oh my god yeah a whole half of her
body was paralyzed for a little bit holy
[ __ ]
yeah i had to do three spinal tap
because they for a c-section they call
it a spinal tap yeah i don't know if
things have changed but back then it was
different
um and
yeah like i remember when they stuck the
needle in like he hit a nerve or
something and so i kind of twitch and
he's like you have to stay still i'm
like this is your fault you made me move
but yeah so like i don't know for me i'm
[ __ ] weird i want to know what the
pain feels like i want to know like
people my mom full experience yeah with
me and my sister she says she wanted to
like feel everything yeah i'm like okay
you do you like i also have her third
was a c-section my brother some people
say that they choose natural birth
because um the medicine like makes it so
numb that they it takes longer because
they can't feel the pushing the pushing
yeah so the labor is longer so then they
choose like oh i'll be in pain so that
way it'll get over faster
but also first time birthday weld me up
too oh i was like and the photos with
isaac being born i was like a balloon
wow this episode is the best birth
control in the world
oh my god i'm gonna go home and crush
all my birth control pills and snort
them wow
okay here's one that's not mother
parenting related um okay so
this one says oh guys do this too to
some extent but um being shamed for
natural functions uh women are more
likely i feel to be judged or to judge
body hair wrinkles gray hairs etc um
beauty standards do you see that do you
find that to be true yeah yeah yeah yeah
but i accept it
i mean for sure but i don't judge it on
anybody else yeah you do what you want
to do with your body but i'm gonna do
what i want to do with mine and i want
to be hairless and wrinkle-free for as
long as i can
like yeah i see people who are like oh
why doesn't she shave her armpits
because you know like those natural
people they don't shave at all yeah it's
like let her do personally i don't like
that because on me yeah on me same
yeah that's the whole point yeah my body
my choice right the other way around
that i do get this
why do you get botox why do you get
plastic surgery that is the judgment
that i received
you should be happy with what you had
that's the other judgment i get from
women a lot of the times of course but i
mean what are i'm still living in my
happy wrinkle free life yeah like it
doesn't really stop yeah i can't frown
right now yeah
and i like it that way me too and we're
having a pleasant experience because i
don't ever think you're mad at me
[Laughter]
but that's what i got too because i got
my boobs done 10 years ago you know
before it was like i mean it was still
pretty popular but now like plastic
surgery dude before was cool i was young
i was like one of those old school ones
you guys wouldn't know but people were
like oh you don't love your body why are
you getting boobs why are you blah blah
like you clearly hate yourself yeah like
no i love myself so much that if this is
the only vessel that i get for the rest
of my life i'm going to decorate it the
way i want to yeah exactly just like
anything else like what's wearing makeup
makeup is just to enhance your
appearance
femininity also judges you for that
true i am naturally beautiful i don't
know how you can wear all that makeup
also the natural girls say that they get
judged by people being like wear some
makeup like why don't you i mean it just
seems like a judge anyway from being a
woman
yeah yeah no matter what exactly always
that's going to say something yeah but
that's the other way i get it i don't
really really really hair thing though i
did find myself um
i
i don't personally i don't like body
hair and i like to shave it all off but
um i do remember like there was a time
where i had
the what's it called the landing strip
pubes instead of like the
shaved completely off and a boyfriend
requested it to be shaved and i felt a
little like weird about it but then
after i did it i was like oh [ __ ] i
actually love this so i personally love
it and then um the armpit thing i did
find myself
stopping when i saw armpit hair like if
i'm scrolling on instagram and then i
see someone with or when i first saw it
it was startling to me and then i had to
check myself and be like wait why am i
why am i startled by that it's because
i'm so conditioned to see nothing there
when someone when a woman raises her
hand to see nothing there and it really
made me think because this was like in
my mid-20s and i i just had never seen
someone so brazenly like before body
hair and it changed my perspective
completely because i thought this woman
was like super confident and super
gorgeous and yeah um i just was yeah it
was white i was like why am i so alarmed
by that i think it's definitely those
internalized beauty standards that we
have because even if you told me like
it's fine to leave your body hair like
it is so internalized yeah i can't even
fight it i won't let it grow yeah for me
it's because i'm just uncomfortable with
it yeah i just don't like it yeah good
like it's prickly for me personally i'm
just like no i like it smooth that's my
laser yeah yeah i do find myself too
like being kind of like startled or like
taken aback a little bit
when seeing something perfectly natural
and normal yeah and it's the freaking
conditioning it's the conditioning and
also i think it's like yeah your
self-judgments because when i was a kid
uh all
all my cousins got to shave their legs
before me and my mom like wasn't gonna
let me shave my legs until later and i
had like the longest freaking leg hair
and it was super embarrassing for me to
go to the swimming pool and like all the
other girls had like their shaved legs
and i just hated it because i thought
it made me look manly and i didn't want
to look like a boy like when i was
younger i just wanted
i wanted to be like the cute popular
girl like i was watching clueless and
you know it's like that era of like you
want to be cute and stuff and i felt
like a boy and then also i had extra
hair above my lip you know
i have like no arm hair but i have like
extra facial hair and extra
like leg hair and why is that so cute
that i just imagined you was like a
little fuzz oh kids were making fun of
me for it and i felt like a man like i
felt like i looked like a man and i
didn't like it and i was really
embarrassed about it so i think because
i was so conscious about it you uh you
like see it right away so you know right
and i relate hard to that yeah like i
actually narrowed my upper lip in middle
school same and then it i just burned it
i did it
and so i have like a little burn spot in
the corner and then i go to school i'm
all [ __ ] embarrassed and people like
is that a cold store i'm like yeah
people thought yeah
what oh yes yes it's a cold sore i was i
was right i was ready to take a cold
sore over them knowing that i was trying
to get rid of my mustache that's so
funny yeah i was like yup it's a cold
tour i got a gold star
oh and then my mom she didn't let me
pluck my eyebrows and my best friend at
the time she had like she incepted me
with it because she was like you have a
unicorn
she was like joking like like like uh
what is that poking fun at me and it was
just like tiny little
tiny hairs but because of that i was
[ __ ] like oh my god i have a unibrow
i'm frida kahlo like oh my god i have to
i have to like
this oh and i'm trying to explain to
this generation like the 90s everyone
had razor thin brows like it was not
cool to have thick brows and i had such
thick brows dude so i asked my mom if i
could have tweezers she's like no
tell me why i was so
i was so determined that i [ __ ]
plucked my eyebrows with my nails oh my
god i plucked my eyebrows with my nails
for many years because she wouldn't let
me pluck and also my legs so you're
talking about your legs i wanted to
shave my legs too you plus your leg hair
yes
that's not always i did it once but with
your fingers yes with my fingers i
literally plucked it because i'm like
i'm not being hairy
wow yeah oh you were like committed i
did like i tried i found a pair of
tweezers and i tried one hair now it
hurts so bad to me that that was like
weird ugly dude that's what i'm telling
you i'm weird because i actually like
the pain
that is a psychological maybe thing i i
liked it that's why i would pierce my
own [ __ ] like my ears my nose like i
like i i can find pleasure in pain
that's why i'm like i'm looking forward
to birth
see what that's like
you're a masochist we're looking forward
to hearing your birth story yeah yeah
it was so
[Music]
[Laughter]
being pregnant because of the
progesterone like a lot of extra
hormones like i'm hairier now yeah like
i have like thicker hair so then even my
laser stuff like i'm getting like little
whiskers i'll even plug these out and i
don't feel anything like it doesn't
really hurt
i don't know i'm weird i've told you i'm
weird your skin's made me like numb from
you just plucking [ __ ] baby you're like
i felt so much emotional pain this is
nothing for real dude
i really wish i'm actually kind of
surprised like i didn't i didn't take
the step further and like
you know like go and like self-harm like
i i didn't do that but yeah like i don't
know i can like meditate or something
and then find like be curious about the
pain that's what happens i can be
curious about what the pain feels like
oh you would like yoga then
yeah i do i love yoga because that was
the hardest part for me was like like
learning how to breathe through the pain
and then like
get flexible and open up you and i are
such opposites i want to be put to sleep
for everything everything
sedate me i don't want to feel any of
that i understand the whole personal
goal thing though because if it's like a
goal and i'm like okay i've never done
this and i've always thought i couldn't
do it it's an experience i'm an
experienced person yeah
a lot of confidence too knowing that i
can
maybe do it i'm still like i don't know
you're going to be kind of doing it go
ahead yeah no but because when i went in
to go get that procedure done for isaac
i was already in labor right and they
asked me like what's your pain level
right now from zero to ten and i was
like i don't know like a point five like
a one and then the nurse stopped and she
looked at me she's like you're having a
really strong contraction right now like
really and i'm like yeah i don't know
just
what did i feel like like cramps yeah it
feels like cramps but like because your
uterus is literally the whole belly just
feels like a cramp around your whole
belly
i'm going to be such a baby i cannot
handle
that the more you fight pain the more it
hurts that's true so that's why i'm like
this is like embracing embracing i'm
like trying to just embrace it breathe
through it just be curious about it i
don't know that's why i'm i'm really
looking forward to birth
oh man i'm sure you guys have gone
through this one this is probably the
one i relate to the most
but the one that's like okay when women
in workplaces from form clicks and cut
out anyone they deem to be an outsider
oh yeah
there's a there's a joke going around to
talk right now saying that women who
went to beauty school are the biggest
bullies like like your bullies in high
school either became a nurse or they
went to bully or into a beauty that's so
true
or they become a lawyer because my bully
became a lawyer and i'm like yeah she
had a lot of like
aggression my my bully went and became a
nurse and then this other girl that i
knew that was terrible is also in beauty
school oh my gosh and that's that's like
the stereotype now but they say that you
know like they form clicks and stuff and
if you're different than them then they
just [ __ ] treat you like [ __ ] yeah or
they like whisper and then they like
kind of laugh at you but they can't dude
i went through that in like elementary
and middle school when i first got here
to america but in high school and
college i didn't really go through that
and i was never a bully so it's not like
i was like that person you know
but in
elementary for sure i did go through it
in middle school i went through it
because i didn't know english but then
like after that i mean now my adulthood
i guess i just don't have the space
and the emotional capacity to tolerate
those people so i just cut them out yeah
literally we have the benefit of like we
don't go to a workplace where we're
forced to be there and like be around
them yeah because i do feel like it's
just like you uh like people just
repeat the roles that they've always
played so if that's who they were in
high school then that's where they
become in their their workplaces
they don't grow so yeah
we don't go to we don't go to work yeah
yeah i wanted to ask you stacey
like
you know we're both mexican
and i only grew up with mainly mexicans
like in my family all that like vacation
everything was just around mexican so
that's my whole bubble that's my whole
world i did know people from other
ethnicities but in a predominantly
mexican neighborhood right so for me i
grew up thinking like
damn mexican not all of them obviously
but like a lot of mexican women are
catty and to like really gossipy really
like
trying to pit other women against each
other like
i personally in my opinion feel like
it's really ingrained in our culture
because that's what i grew up with but
do you agree with me
so
i would say
yes and i hate to admit it because i
personally don't think that i'm like
that yeah but for example the city that
i'm from it's a small cities uh
so in mochi's it's really small and
there's a lot like the social class
levels are very apparent over there like
the difference between private and
public school is
so huge and so for example there's like
the country club and there's like you
have to go to the one private school if
you even want to have like the positive
relationships to grow up and have a
successful business you know because
if you're the contractor who does
drywall everybody in the city goes to
you and if you're not popular if you're
not in the right circles then nobody's
going to give you business right
so yeah it does happen and like in
elementary i went over there and that's
the kind of social
struggle that i had because like we were
well enough to have money where i was
going to private school but we weren't
well enough so that i could have all the
expensive things and that i was going on
the expensive trips right so
i was you i would say like the poorer of
the
well and well-off people
um in my younger years so yeah did that
definitely like was a thing and even
like when i went older and i went back i
had like i went to a i was part of a
bachelorette trip
and i hadn't had a relationship with
people from over there in a really long
time and just seeing the dynamic of like
girls in their 20s like mexican girls in
their 20s like i was i went on this trip
over there i was just like oh my god
this is crazy because here in america
it's very much like say to my face
in mexico it's like oh my god i don't
like her can you believe her like she's
wearing that blah blah blah fake as [ __ ]
but in front of her you're like oh my
god girl like you're so nice i love that
you're here
that's that quality that i'm like
mexican [ __ ] have this yeah why are
they like why are we like this because
i'm part of this group
you care more about people what they're
going to say about you so you would
never go up to somebody and be like i
heard you were talking [ __ ] yeah you
would be like can you believe that tiff
was saying this about me or can you
believe that tiff did this so over there
you try to stay face as much as possible
so you would never go directly to
somebody and tell them i need you to
stop talking crap about my child you
would just pretend like you're okay with
them to save face
in front of everybody else so yes
girls are terrifying yeah girls are wild
okay we're gonna actually take another
quick break listen to our sponsors they
are wonderful people and wonderful
companies and
we highly suggest them whatever we're
saying right now uh as the world becomes
increasingly uncomfortable we're all
looking for as much comfort as we can
get and the one thing i can always count
on is how comfortable my purple mattress
is uh the purple mattress is a mattress
unlike any i've ever seen before because
they have like this purple grid thing on
it as opposed to springs or memory foam
like other mattresses
uh that's because purple is comfort
reinvented only purple has the grid a
stretchy gel material that's amazingly
supportive for your back and legs while
cushioning your shoulders necks
and hips i don't know how it does it but
it's it's pretty fantastic and it's my
favorite color because of how it's
designed the grid does not trap air
air actually circulates and flows
through it so you'll never overheat
the grid bounces back as you move and
shift unlike memory foam which remembers
everything that's why memory foam has
craters and divots and right now you can
try your purple mattress risk free with
free shippings and returns financing is
also available purple really is comfort
for an uncomfortable world right now
you'll get 10 off any order of 200 or
more go to purple.com big mood 10 and
use the promo code big mood 10. that's
purple.com big mood 10 promo code big
mood 10 for 10 off any order of 200 or
more again that's purple.com big mood 10
promo code big mood 10 terms apply and
now for a quick shout out to our sponsor
nutrafull did you know that 30 million
women are impacted by weakened or
thinning hair if you're among them no
you're not alone and that there is a
solution you can trust to deliver
results that's where neutral comes in
neutral supports healthy hair growth
from within by targeting the five root
causes of thinning which are stress
hormones environment nutrition and
metabolism
neutrophil is physician formulated to be
100 drug free they use medical grade
botanicals in consistently effective
dosages so you get the most reliable
results thousands of women have taken
back control of their hair with neutral
foal with many users raving that the
supplement not only transformed their
hair but restored their confidence too
you can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
nutrafold.com and entering the promo
code big mood to save 15 off your first
month's subscription this is their best
offer anywhere and it is only available
to us customers for a limited time plus
free shipping on every order get 15 off
at nutrifoal.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l-com
promo code big mood so wait to to finish
off that point i would just say it's
literally like a novella like i think we
grew up watching them so much that
people genuinely like to play them
and it's that's what it is i think
that's what it is one of the things and
that's so like disappointing it is but i
mean though you got to take the good
with the battle right i still love being
mexican and i'm still the same i love it
yeah i'll speak it till then
i will never stop saying it yeah and
then i mean obviously like that's just
one tiny little perspective on the the
culture or like the personalities
because women like on the other end of
it
they're like so loving so warm so
inviting yeah like
you know
exactly what i was saying too is like be
warm and be nice to your face you might
touch your feet on your back but
like at least yeah i don't know you just
gotta accept them and take them for what
they are you know that's even sometimes
in some of our families you know it's
crazy though i literally i have as one
aunt who she's so
blunt
she literally like she'll she'll go to
my mom and she'll be like oh marielena
like you've gained so much weight oh
geez gosh so you're not on a diet like
she's like that you look so healthy
that's how my filipino that's nicer
my grandma but she does it like are you
having a baby or you just gained weight
you know like that because
my aunt's like that too so so then like
that's i guess kind of rare
in our culture because no one's like no
they'll be like oh my god you look so
good we're so happy to see you and then
when you leave oh she looked like she
gained weight huh and then your mom will
tell you your tia said that you look
like you gained weight and you're like
yeah yeah
yeah
so that's i feel like happened to me in
friend groups in like middle school and
in high school elementary all like all
through that i felt like i never could
form but didn't you go to private
schools no oh yeah public yeah and uh
well you were poor yeah yeah gross yeah
here not a lot of people usually go to
private private yeah in mexico that's
the thing right because that's what i
was thinking because maybe here i not
that i'm in those circles but here maybe
in private schools there's more money
like if you go to public school it's
probably we all me our parents all made
around the same amount of money so we
were all like yeah the normal social
class you know and then maybe people in
public school i mean private schools but
that's i don't know
when i got to the us i stopped
experiencing that in high school and
college oh interesting yeah but yeah
because i got better at cutting people
off like if you notice i'm just like you
took shape so so what happened for me i
made friends with people online in chat
rooms and then also like a lot of guy
friends so i mostly had guy friends in
high school and then after
um high school and college and so um
and with all my boyfriends it was like
we were okay with being friends with our
exes and all that stuff until steve and
steve had introduced this role of like
hey we shouldn't be friends like
be like friends friends with opposite
sex where you like stay up all night
talking to someone and single and stuff
and so this is where
we were
you had brought up about how you think
that boys and girls can't be friends and
um i had my mind changed on that because
i was on the other side where i had
mostly guy friends and then steve
brought up a lot of great points and it
made me change my mind how did you come
to that because i know that's what a lot
of people wanted to hear about like
we've been teasing it for a couple
episodes and i know jess wanted to hear
about it yeah so okay so this is
definitely me i'm on this the side with
like my friends are all guys because
yeah games like these are dudes i play
games with everybody yeah all my
interests were guy oriented like yeah
comedy and sports and all that stuff
yeah yeah so i think maybe we should
start off by saying that this is
obviously my only experience
and
i think it rings true in my life and
everybody's different
but i just genuinely
don't comprehend what you could even
ever have in common with a man
and this is obviously me i'm in a
relationship with a guy in a romantic
relationship with a guy like what could
i possibly talk to
or talk about or like go out and do with
the guy who's my friend when i have my
partner
you know like what what are you doing
like yeah even that point of like
speaking on the phone with somebody too
late at night
why would i ever allow danny to have
that close relationship with someone
yeah and for i guess we're not allowable
yeah like it's not allowed but it's like
why do they want to spend that much time
on the phone with someone instead of
spending time in our relationship when
time is so precious and sorry to cut you
off but most affairs start emotionally
yes yeah exactly and so i never really
thought about any of that and then he
brought up a few points of just like why
would you want just like even that to be
there like even if neither of us are
jealous or anything but like even that
to be a thought in your mind that i
might like someone outside of our
relationship is like something i would
never want to happen or be encroached on
and then i started thinking about all my
guy friends that i was friends with in
high school and in college and stuff and
um
and i always thought like oh guys and
girls can definitely be friends and
stuff but then after in between
relationships yeah they did try to make
moves on me
so so steve was like yeah there's always
someone whether it's you or them that
you kind of start getting feelings if
you're spending enough one-on-one time
together and i was like huh yeah because
it was never me gaining the feelings but
they obviously were because after when i
was single so then this situation that
we're specifically talking about is the
girl is in a relationship and she's
and then being friends with a single guy
so you could both be in a relationship
it's just a one-on-one like you're
spending a lot of time with
someone in the op on the opposite sex
yeah yeah because i don't know if i if i
fully agree like have like a hard
yeah [ __ ] no because
i think it's circumstantial it is
circumstantial especially with the type
of relationships that you have because
like i have always had
good guy friends that
are either in a relationship or they're
not and
not that i would like go out of my way
to like plan a date with them or
anything
i mean i yeah i guess maybe like i have
had lunch dates with guy friends
that's not weird to you yeah i mean
because they're they're not even like i
wouldn't i wasn't even seeing them as
like friends they were like brothers so
like family that's the same thing with
me also because i have guy friends
friendly i've known since high school
right and then like once a year once or
well i don't really see my friend's
period anyways but once a year once
every two years we go on like a a dinner
like an expensive dinner like we're
successful we did this let's catch up
and that's it oh you're both single no
it's a guy and a girl or it's multiple
guys seeing you it's me and another guy
yeah and this yeah
like we have matching tattoos but then
like we would never touch each other
even when we were both single times no
one ever made moves you know it's the
same thing with the guys that i play
games with like i've been single or like
i break up and no one ever makes moves
with me because like if we ever did we
throw up
i could i could totally see that so i've
been on both sides um it was more about
like your part the way your partner
feels and also um i think there are
caveats i will say like for example um
steve has been on the phone
late of hours with like jess or you or
gina or tiff um helping them through
different advice like just getting they
wanted a male's perspective on something
and i totally didn't mind that at all
because like we're all friends in a
group like and it's not like like
they're frequently talking on the phone
it's just like hey i need advice on this
thing and so it's and they're friends
like i don't think that they aren't
friends you know just friends but it i
think for us and this is all
based on everyone's personal
relationship because like i said all my
exes were like
oh we were both cool with talking to
each other's exes um but you know
personally it's like a relationship is a
set of rules that you and your partner
agree on like it's not one person
restricting the other person yeah it's
just like hey this we both feel
comfortable with this and yeah i think
it's out of like consideration like you
have to be considerate too because even
though i do have friends like that and i
do go out i clear it with my guy not
because he controls me but it's more
like hey you know this is who it is like
you've met him before and i would be
like is that okay you know
i think that's a thing right because
then that becomes
for example like my friends when i got
on with my boyfriend none of my
girlfriends had to be like can we still
be friends yeah because yeah there's
nothing there right
was what if it was a guy and
let's say i had a really close
relationship with the guy and then i got
with denny danny would probably be like
why
like why what's going on right it would
throw him off because it is somebody who
could potentially threaten their
relationship even if
you've been friends forever or you know
like in this scenario
the fact is when things get tough
are you gonna go to that guy yeah
exactly and then is he gonna be like oh
and he's gonna feel like he knows you
better than your partner like that those
are the things where it's like okay i
can see where it crossed the line like
this these are the things that i can
agree with brought up was like okay so
they are being an emotional support for
you and when you're like giving them
intimate details of your life and like
sharing vulnerable things like you would
a partner like a spouse then when you
and your partner have a fight are you
gonna then go to that this year for
emotional support and i was like that
makes a lot of sense i can totally see
that i will never go
to my guy friends
as like a intimate type of vulnerable
you know
source of uh support i i do like my
group of guys that i hang out and play
games with i do because we are the same
for each other we're like each other's
support system but it's never crossed
the line yeah like you know do you want
to come over and comfort me whatever
something like that it's more like we
talk in video games online like if you
and your boyfriend got in a fight like
would you go to that group of guys and
yeah because it's about him yeah because
i want a guy's perspective i'm not like
every fight you know yeah but it's like
i want a guy's perspective
um and then i also go to the girls too
so for me it's like an evil kind of
thing yeah me too because yeah like i
literally have done that yeah i
literally have done
you know that's what i'm saying that so
my coffee is like okay but it's like
we're all a group of friends and then
somebody has helped with something right
that's different to you yeah being
someone that's outside of our friendship
group that you met before yeah yeah
well if let's say nick and steve weren't
together and nikki wasn't here i don't
think you
i don't know you guys really ship that
well but i don't think you would go out
of your way to call steve if steve was a
single guy if you if he was just a
single guy living in his apartment by
himself and you were having problems
with casey you wouldn't be like hey
steve single guy who lives in the house
that's also irrelevant because i'm like
you're single you can't help me like
yeah i need i need like a right
husband's perspective he's the husband
of one of your close friends yeah he's
not just steve like he's a close person
in your life yeah and if we're talking
about like
seeking um
the emotional
whatever it was
support that's the word if you're
seeking emotional support so i had this
guy
that back when i worked at the hospital
um we used to carpool together sometimes
because his he used to work at best buy
and it was like down the street from my
hospital so there were times where we
would carpool and
i was single some of that time when we
actually were carpooling and he had
never made any moves like i would go to
his house all the time because i was
really close to his sister too
and so like that was that's like a guy
friend that comes to mind where i'm like
wait like we would never cross that line
and he was there for me i'd be there for
him i knew his whole family he knew mine
like
i don't like even like i would uh his
sister would sometimes watch isaac for
me like we were more like family like
it's not even like uh
we were really close but i also wouldn't
go to him for emotional support like not
it wasn't that like we wouldn't we
weren't that close so where is he now
yeah so
just we just drifted like we don't
really nothing really happened it's just
like he lives his life and i live mine
and yeah and if we so happen to keep in
contact then that's [ __ ] awesome and
then you can meet casey because casey's
never met him so but like
i think the difference here is like when
i say friend i mean like a meaning like
a friendship yeah yeah yeah your
relationship hanging out with all the
time texting yeah yeah because
i've had those friends too like i
actually had one the one guy friend i
had who didn't but um i we used to both
do crossfit and we used to live in the
same apartment complex we would drive
together to the gym work out together
and leave and never never did either of
us ever hit on each other but that
friendship or that acquaintance was
based on
that like it's not like we were like
talking about yeah i have these really
deep feelings about this and that you
know so i think there's a difference
between an acquaintance that kind of
serves a purpose in your life like
giving your right
or convenience or whatever and then a
person who you're like this guy is so
cool and i love him so much and we're
best friends and we're hanging out
together and he's looking at the mall
right now and we're doing selfies at the
mall yeah yeah yeah
that's maybe the level of friendship
that we're not we hadn't thought about
you know so is it possible that a guy
and a girl out there are friends right
now and they've never touched each other
yes
it is yeah and is it is that what i want
for my relationship no i wouldn't i
don't think that's something that we
need
i personally in my relationship like i
have my group of girlfriends and he has
this group of guy friends and i do think
it's healthy for us to spend time away
from each other doing our own thing and
he goes and plays volleyball and i go
hang out with the girls um but if there
was another woman who he was like hey
good morning michelle yeah and he's like
what are you doing today oh i'm at work
and you know
that's like yeah i like you yeah that's
a friend exactly but that's a friend
yeah so i think the definition of
friendship is what people get heated
about yeah because when we're talking
about friends we're talking about like
your friends like best friend like for
example you said like he goes to his guy
friends you go to your girlfriends i i
go to i play poker every night with a
group of guys it's just poker i'm there
to take their money like that's right
business we chit-chat and stuff and like
we're like you know teasing each other
and picking on each other but like it's
all guys there's maybe one other girl
that pops in here and there but it's
usually like all guys but that's it's
just my interest yeah we don't we don't
text each other we don't talk to each
other outside of poker we just play
poker together and that's it that's my
time away yeah from steve um but i
literally don't have anyone in my life
that i just text yeah you guys only are
green
we're not super active in our group chat
either but you guys are the ones that i
would go to for any little thing but
it's not even like i
it's not even every little thing yeah i
go to steve for every little thing and
then yeah and then any girl things that
i'm like steve couldn't answer this or
he couldn't relate then i go to the
group chat before because that's what
your partner is right like that's that
person that you chose to share yeah your
life with so i mean yeah is it possible
to have a guy friend yeah i'll call it a
guy acquaintance you know men are great
and they're needed and they're
loving and yeah yeah like i don't hate
men i i'm in love with one you know
right
it's just that as great as they are i
don't have a lot in common with them for
friendship grounds i think it's fun
hanging out in a group like yeah you
know they're fun i love joking around
like guys
tend to in general have a little bit of
a different sense of humor than women i
feel like i
i
like meld with that better because i saw
a lot of roasting and a lot of like you
know teasing each other but like busting
balls i like to bust balls that makes me
feel good and that's like but a lot of
women don't like that and i found out
the hard way
because i really didn't mean to insult
people and i was just thought we were
like oh this is me showing you that
you're a better you're one of my close
friends you know and uh and they didn't
like it so it's fun for me in a group
setting to like
talk to guys or hang out with them joke
with them but that's it that's where it
ends like there's no outside texting
there's no
like yeah so i guess that makes sense
too because my guy friends it's not like
i hit them up everybody like hey what
are you doing let's hang out with them
all yeah so it's more like let's go
shopping like let's play games yeah yeah
yeah because that's like your job and
what you enjoy to do but when you have
your partner i'm sure you're like babe
this is how my day was i'm at work or
i'm gonna play or stream or you know
what you do i will always talk to my
significant other more obviously yeah
that is my best friend
um so that makes sense yeah i have my
friends in their settings and like when
we do go out to eat
um maybe sometimes it's one on one or
whatever but most of the time it's in a
group yeah yeah okay that makes sense
that's healthy so yeah i didn't even
think about that until i started dating
steve and i got converted yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah it's just the healthiest thing to
do and i feel like
leave no room for doubt yeah i want you
to be i want you to know i'm all about
you and there's no one else that could
ever
disrespect and anything that i have to
give i will give to you exactly
emotionally and obviously physically too
and if there's like a reason that you're
talking outside of the relationship it's
like oh it's for this specific yeah yeah
yeah oh i just wanted to confide in her
about blah blah blah it's like why not
come find me your therapist
yes i'm trying to think about it too
like the other way around
like because for me like obviously
number one is my partner's comfort
comfortable comfortable
yeah it's easier to say that um yeah
that's obviously number one so then i'm
thinking like well if it's the other way
around
would i be bothered if he had like a
really close
girlfriend that wasn't in our group that
wasn't in our group that i didn't know
no i wouldn't like i wouldn't be
comfortable with with her him being
close to someone that is not close to me
yeah right because
that's my i think that's my boundary
that's my boundary i have to be close to
her too yeah and i have to know her and
i have to be involved in her life and
yeah i agree with that yeah
know who she is like yeah like i need to
know who you are that's why like
whenever there are guys in my life which
i don't think there has been outside
guys from our relationship because all
of my guy friends were his guy friends
first but
if there were to be a like that guy i
just talked about like if he would enter
my life again like i would make sure for
[ __ ] sure that first of all casey's
comfortable with him coming into my life
number two that casey gets to know him
and is close to him and it has a
relationship with him because then i
wouldn't feel comfortable yeah i make it
a point to introduce them
and like have them hang out and stuff so
you
know
who yeah exactly i love when everyone's
in relationships because then all the
guys could hang out and all the girls
that's fun
but anyway that we have there's a lot
more in the in the toxic femininity
stuff um that we didn't get to but a lot
of it is you get the gist right it's
like women judging other women for not
womaning right and if there's something
that we didn't get to let us know in the
comments if you've ever felt any sort of
toxic femininity because it's something
that's not discussed as much as toxic
masculinity which is like basically a
lot of men are saying like you're just
bashing us for being men and it's like
well i think that women uh have been
pretty fair in the bashing actually
so
in the comments what you think and also
check out our sponsors and check out
stacy's all of her stuff she's got a
youtube channel she's got a jewelry line
she's got an instagram and she just got
engaged so
congrats to her and
subscribe and we'll see you next week
bye apodaca jules